testing testing this is great oh
speaking at a reasonable volume oh this
is Fred this is my turn
talking
good afternoon everyone and welcome once
again to today's episode of the Friday
app review my name is reto Meier I'm
joined here in the studio by Fred oh and
we've got a bunch of apps to look I said
I think we've got six apps on the list
I'm gonna see how many we can get
through in the next 40 minutes or so all
right let's not waste any time let's get
stuck right into it
first off today we have this is original
we have an alarm clock we can't get
enough of these alive please sending
them in um so this is really the last
alarm clock we're going to look at for a
little while so it's got Zen alarms in
alarm all right so I expect the study
Zen okay that looks kind of cool all
right so we've got we've got a zen-like
picture here blue nice sort of simple UI
I will note that the it's not just your
video the the little moon icon down the
bottom yet it's a little bit fuzzy it's
a little bit fuzzy so I'm a little
concerned that that's not set at the
appropriate resolution for my screens at
my eyes or does that look yeah it's
fuzzy for you too okay yeah yeah very
fuzzy not as fuzzy okay so we have a
menu item so I'm gonna hit that
so get alarm Pro go home so one of the
things that that you'll note here are
looking at these menu icons is that
they're sort of a mishmash so the Home
icon looks like it's something from go
ahead and say Froyo gingerbread I'm not
sure it's got the GREs effect but it's
it's not quite the the straight
monochrome of the other ones whereas the
others look like they're custom sort of
designed specifically so this and and
the alarm Pro icon is in full color 3d
so this illustrates a couple of bad
practices one is that you shouldn't be
using color for your menu icon icons and
the other thing is that there's a danger
here if you sort of use the built-in
icons for any of the particular versions
of the OS they're going to start to
mismatch so the ones you have which are
custom which are going to be Const
and the other ones are going to change
to see what I build them all and you
want them all to look the same and
consistent otherwise you get this kind
of weird effect here where it's like
well they all look kind of different
when I'm expecting them all to look the
same consistency yeah exactly and
actually you know that the Settings icon
which is down the bottom here there is a
standard icon to use for that so again I
probably use that if possible but a
wrench is a wrench is reasonable people
are going to know what that means if we
go into settings we have a Zen alarm
push the screen to continue as a general
set okay so we've got here kind of a
workflow wizard to-do list again the
text here is a little sorry I'm ruining
a focus yeah yes this approach seems to
be pretty popular these days when it's
the overlay translucent or transparent
instruction not you know screen to
illustrate how to use a particular app
what I usually found tricky is that the
alignments don't always work out well
hmm depend on different screen size
that's very good point yeah
so it's interesting in this example in
particular looks like they've used an
image for the instructions so it's a
little bit squashed and a little bit out
of focus so that's maybe one way that
they've tried to make it all fit but but
even still you can see at the top here
that the Zen alarm tutorial push the
screen to continue first start that's
generally referred to a swiping rather
than pushing unless they know pushing
doesn't work interesting so the arrow is
a little bit deceptive it says push it
says push it looks like a soirée that
was my first intuition - yeah the
expecting to have to go like this but
and with the overlay screen with some
tacks on it and on the main screen you
also have some text it became less
legible that way when it absolutely so
yeah and having it in the settings
screen is kind of new as well so I mean
there's the settings here should be
simple enough to be self-explanatory so
you probably don't need a wizard there
if you feel the need to have a wizard
that often a clue that your app is
unnecessarily complicated so sometimes
it's good if you've got something which
is really simple once you understand
and so you just want to help people walk
walk through that first attempt then it
makes sense for something like an alarm
clock you shouldn't really need a
tutorial or a guided step-by-step
instructions to be able to set an alarm
or a you know a clock of any client so
maybe rethink that okay so in the
settings screen we've got show weather
weather in Celsius instead of Fahrenheit
so I guess I'm text-to-speech technology
oh yeah text-to-speech volume
crank that up stop playing music in
sleep mode after 30 minutes so this is
all fairly self-explanatory I personally
would have preferred to see this in a
standard settings screen I kind of
prefer all the settings to look
consistent with the system settings it's
cheap it's easy and it provides that
consistency which just makes the app
feel a little nicer there's no real
reason to have excuse me there's no real
reason to have this this picture in the
background here you don't necessarily
need as much as in when you're setting
things up also because you've got ads
you Zen is already ruined so all right
so I prefer my weather in Celsius
instead of Fahrenheit so I'm gonna leave
it as it is afraid we'll just have to
make do all right so we'll go back what
else do we have here the alarm list
create new alarm settings okay so if we
just look at it as it is it's basically
just showing us a nice picture the time
and I get the the weather up here the
Sun icon could be a little bit bigger I
think yeah it seems like a lot of empty
space which you know I get it because
the whole points supposed to be the Zen
looking image I guess it'll be
interesting to see whether this image
changes I don't know if you've had it
installed long enough to to notice the
weather to change we're in we're in
Mountain View so it should be not sunny
in about six months so yeah we could
hang out maybe we come back to this if
it will do it if the weather has changed
next week then we will reopen this but I
don't like your chances no you want us
to set in a lot absolutely interesting
interesting
okay well let's say let's actually do
the the point of the app and set an
alarm so I'm going to try and press the
little moon button cuz see what that
does Oh
in sound quality interesting I'm by
field
tranquil Frank
like I need to go to the bathroom so
this is a fountain at a park
let's see spring birds near the first
three around okay no that's fair I like
that as well because you can see the all
the options and you you're told what is
the advantage here of paying extra so
let's go with blue water ocean which
means they would need to download two
more in two comma eight okay so this is
actually a good example so I'm going to
go ahead and guess that the developer is
not in England or the US so in a lot of
countries so here you generally would
use a 2.08 to indicate it a decimal and
a lot of countries it's a comma this is
a good example where using localization
to do the formatting for you is a good
tip because this looks weird to me yeah
and I'm sure it looks correct to the
developer but it it's causes a little
bit of cognitive dissonance in Android
there's some there's a built-in
framework to make them again easy for
developers to arrange to take advantage
of localization yeah and then you can
just say what the number isn't and let
the localization on the device fix that
for you so I'm going to download that
see ya this guy's pretty quick alright
so we clear the download boom
let's play it alright so one tip here as
well as you've got the OK button
I'd kind of use a standard button if
possible wow that's getting a little out
of focus very blurry on my side there we
go
alright so we can change the sound so
that's what it sounds like I don't know
how well that comes across all right I'm
feeling very zen ok so we get back let's
it be a lot so for a start here
particularly if you've got no alarm set
I would kind of like it to be more
obvious how to set it so that's one of
the tips of the reasons why we have this
action bar paradigm is to make those
primary actions more visible because
here I think you need to go into the
into the menu so anything in the menu
you can kind of think of that as
secondary actions which a lot of your
users are never been find so things like
settings home potentially are fine but
things like create new alarm which is
sort of central to this app you want
that front and center ok let's have a
look a long time so if I click on that
that's fine this thinks it's
8:14 p.m. every five minutes the key to
choosing date weeks s repeat alarm every
five minutes I was i wonder what's the
practical use of oh yeah see all that
still installed air core it's a good
example of why that isn't always the
most preferred option okay so what
happens about you sample stream so I can
choose a file so what I would select
here is rather than having this filename
which is I guess the placeholder if I
haven't explicitly set it a better
option here might be you know custom
custom file which would be nice yeah
okay so we'll leave it at fountain at
the park it's save so again the saving
cancel button so we've kind of gone with
some of the more standard buttons but at
least make sure you've got them in the
right way yeah you guys see the contrast
here the system dialog box popped up
with the black theme dark theme as
compared with custom buttons it gives
yeah it's right away you've got this
this dissonance right it's like well the
system says this but the the save and
cancel button look different so why do
they look different they should look the
same so you can customize your your
alert dialogues a better option would be
perhaps to to not customize your own
buttons so I haven't chosen a weekday
one idea again here might be to set a
default so look click here to choose a
date
trying to click alright so let's see
select working days and weekends because
it's always time for Zen alright hit
save
okay so we got alarm has been activated
next to life starts and I can almost
read that in time during the toast and
so it's got it here because I took so
long
it's no you're gonna be set until
tomorrow so let's let's try this 17 Sept
save excellent another sort of tip there
is that that process if I'm sort of
modifying something it should just be
modified by default so perhaps hitting
back can cancel it out we just need an
okay it just feels like there's too many
sort of settings there I just want to be
able to change it hit back and it easy
changed right can you head home and go
back
that's whatever if it shows up in deed
notification mm-hmm those look like no
it doesn't look like but in general it's
good practice to have you have set
something let the user know in the
notification shade that a and alarms
been set it's active so what is it hello
just came off this is the alarm this is
the alarm mode in order to stop the
alarm so do you think we're on the
screen which is great to continue okay
so this is a great example where this is
probably not necessary
so maybe yeah very weird things are
happening here so maybe you know deposit
alarm you can have button an image
button of some sort on the screen
indicating a press to pass the alarm or
something instead of having that overlay
screen hmm and in particular so this
something is definitely weird going on
with your text here looks like it's
displaying two text fields on top of
each other and one of them is going away
I want to say that you're trying to do
sort of some sort of failing in and out
animation and it's definitely not
working on on the Galaxy Nexus here so
the other thing I notice it and I know
you guys definitely might be able to
tell this but the alarm is the volume is
increasing we're gonna have to cut this
short because I'm gonna need a bathroom
break it just keeps up but yeah okay so
nice so when I cancel the alarm it it
tells me what time it is and tells me
what the what the weather forecast is
which is which is nice so I can decide
screw it I'm gonna sleep in for another
half hour because it's raining or
alternatively I better get up at 6 a.m.
and then change the background to a
different one this time yes so that that
changes and did it start to fade in I
feel like it started to get brighter but
nobody knows my imagination so I gave me
about the next alarm starts in so I can
hit stop alarm so effectively by
pressing it I'm snoozing and I if I have
to hit stop alarm to make it stop and
I'm gonna be torn here cuz half of me
wants to say make that stop alarm button
really really big so that I can just
whack it one it's next to my bed I mean
there are two primary options at this
point
you had to stop be the snooze hmm so
make these two very very prominent so
that they use us know how to react do it
exactly because if I can't hit the stop
alarm button then my next option is to
throw the phone across the room and
that's going to get expensive so yeah
it's it's stopped and we go back to the
to the mains end screen alright so
overall I say again for this sort of
main screen I think you can possibly do
a little bit more to improve the the
quality of the the overall look so the
the fonts the the images down the bottom
making sure that they are maybe a little
bit more prominent or at least the right
resolution but the whole like again and
I think we talked about this with an app
last week if aesthetics is kind of the
key selling point of your app you've
really got to focus on that and it's got
to be across the board from your feature
graphic to your icons anything visual
you really have to emphasize that
because that's kind of a whole point as
we know by experience there's like a
million different alarm clock apps all
of which are fighting to compete with an
app which already comes on the phone and
does the job of setting an alarm so you
really if the whole point is this is
beautiful and it's zen-like then you
need to make the whole experience as
smooth and polished as you possibly can
all right so first impression counts
it's very very heavy though the simpler
your app is the more that first
impression counts because I don't need
this to use this app because well I need
an alarm and this is the one I've got
it's like I don't even need to install
an app for this so yeah work on the work
on the details would be my advice oh
okay watch the birdie
all right the produce is messing with me
I'm still sort of puff on camera hop off
camera as well okay that's how you know
it's a professional organization because
we have a cameraman yeah we have a team
at a dedicated team hey Freddie
Jon know they all call you your own call
Dean but that's just a coincidence it's
not that there's just what a guy called
Ian that would be which in switching
yeah exactly we just only hire people
called Ian to keep it simple
okay let's have a look next app is G
tasks which is feels very similar to the
name of an app which we have looked at
recently but it required permission so
this is a yes which do there
yes which the camera view okay perfect
since I'm going to go ahead and assume
based on the permission that it's
requesting that this is an app which is
going to want to provide an interface
for my Google Tasks yeah it's thanks to
thanks for the cloud it looks like
awesome welcome to cloud computing I do
love the cloud what I wouldn't give for
a non autofocusing camera alright focus
on my hands perfect so straight away
that's a little bit confusing so when it
started up for a brief moment it had a
checkbox which had click me or something
written on it and it disappeared oh I
missed that well yeah and that's kind of
a problem
so it seemed like it kind of almost
wanted to give me a tutorial and and now
that option has gone away let's see so
we can of course so you can associate
different of caramel's accounts nice
nice so we can hit refresh we can add
new to-do lists so let's see you yes hi
it doesn't come across clearly across
for the camera for the photo paper
watching but there hey it's a no pet
looking oh yeah you can look a little
gray lights yeah they're almost
invisible on the air on the video but
there there's a little little gray line
to give it that notebook feel I would
say that the text size still seems a
little cramped and even though the
spacing between the lines it feels like
it's smaller very big I can see I can
see why you would do it just to try and
get more text on the screen but yeah it
just feels cramped date and priority oh
this is quite a nice display so here we
can choose the due dates and let's say
before next Friday calendar of today
remind us yeah then and it's weekly
every Friday perfect okay perfect
there's some interesting I'd like to get
your opinion on his radio show go back
to the calendar
so from the previous screen where you
have an action bar and when you go back
we go into the calendar if they research
replace the action bar with confirmation
or cancel ok or cancel what do you think
of its kind of huh this is either like
contextual it kind of is rather
contextual action bar where the only
actions that you want to invite or
either - ok or cancel yeah I mean I
think that there are other apps which do
something similar I want to say
something like the calendar app I'm not
sure office of my head so it's
interesting I think it works in this
case because it's literally the only
action so you can take from this I'm
gonna go ahead and assume that as they
probably can't place these two buttons
anywhere on the screen because you have
so many options to choose from so this
is the bit which I found a little bit
concerning so if I change the date if I
go to 21 so if I hit cancel I would
presume that that doesn't change and it
doesn't if I change it and hit back I
would assume that back is going to be
the bullet of castle and it isn't it
it's implicit it's an implicit okay okay
in this in this instance if I hit back
that I'm saying save I'm so I have to
hit cancel explicitly to cancel the
option and to me that seems backwards if
I get back in this instance I would
expect it to not save so in almost an
explicit save so remember you can change
it to an implicit save okay I don't must
go the other way and so basically just
remove cancel because there's nothing
here that's you don't risk losing a lot
of data you know it's basically just
changing the date and those sorts of
things and so it's quite as urgent so uh
yeah I would basically just cancel the
cancel and just have okay and back is
the way to cancel it to just to go back
to the previous screen so you can't
cancel it yeah that would be my
inclination and the other thing I think
we've done here is so the thing which is
a little bit confusing is that it seems
almost as though the the review apps is
a note associated with this task but the
task itself doesn't have a title so you
kind of got this blank space here we are
yeah
one time you're wondering what this
checkbox is well yeah the textbox is OK
or cancel but like what's the white
space like this seems like notes about
review apps make more notes more boats
that's yeah autocorrect sites and you
say so it goes there and it's sort of
creating this this longer thing but and
you know I kind of would expect this to
look the same in both ways if that makes
sense what if you get four more lines
that's it you wonder how far it goes so
it's hence appending it to it it's
interesting okay okay we have refresh we
have the overflow menu edit tasks lists
which is going to let us have multiple
things and I guess integrate the
calendar as well which is quite
interesting add new tasks I'll sue else
we got this let's trash it three times
for three percent of the new tasks and
that's an interesting way to monetize
that's interesting so you can add up to
three tasks in a free version
what does it batch add actually doing
I'm gonna go back I could try it
yeah batch add bad chef and press enter
new test taught you type something up so
you can enter multiple now just faster
yeah for city great you see so I think
it's going to ignore you but did at it
interesting okay maybe that they know
that we're reviewing their app yeah
possibly no I suspect that what it is is
batch add as a way of adding tasks to
multiple lists and we only have one list
so that maybe beer that maybe the issue
there okay so I mean overall I think
it's it's a it's a good-looking app it
uses the action bar paradigm they assume
that it has a landscape mate yeah oh
that's interesting so when I switched to
landscape mode it seems to have lost all
of my
if we create a task under this list
Friday review list yeah I think we only
have one list how about all can try to
get it all in tragic tried to rotate
interesting yeah seems like a bug so it
didn't so it's not associated with
anything so the question is how do you
associate it with a particular list yeah
particularly because he I don't know how
well you can see but it claims that this
five all right right so I'd really
expect to see them here that seems to be
a bug anyway I'm just force close yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna do you a solid and
report this do you wanna have a look
yeah let's have a look at my life
version I'm going to report why Oh a
good citizen rato is working on the bug
reports I'll probably descriptive yeah
let's launch the the G tasks app it's
oops
go back so it's a wide view within a
stretched but with a stretched screen
taking up the whole width of this
application if you go to one of the menu
items to add a note and note and you hit
save it got saved so I would suggest you
know typically on a wider tablet form
factor you would want to introduce some
padding on the side on the right-hand
side and on the left-hand side so that
it doesn't feel like too stretched so
because right now looking at the tablet
optimized version it looks like a little
bit stretched and also you can probably
work on the screen the font size a
little bit by increasing the font size
because at this distance reading the
reading it off up from the tablet it's
not legible because of the small font
size you can switch to different
accounts and overall I think I think in
terms of functions functionality the
version on the phone form factor is you
know identical with the functionality
here you just need to figure out the
layout and and the padding on a tablet
yeah absolutely so I think that's the
the two big pieces of advice here would
be definitely work on a tablet layout or
something like notes and tasks works
really well on tablet and I've seen some
good implementations you know on a
bigger screen it just makes it easier
for people typing longer text exactly
way you've got the situation not yet I
live in Austin all right someone wants
to write a really good word processor I
guess Google Docs and it does a pretty
good job um all the ones which we added
on the on the phone all right there you
go let's go ahead and refresh all right
okay sounds good it's working and there
are a couple messages all right make
sure you look at the cotton why are you
doing it cotton is your google play were
to receive which I added by using the
app 2 tasks feature of Gmail and I have
to use it google play order receipt
because that's the only mail discount
awesome excellent so this is well I
guess it adds the yeah yeah yeah well
there is some email no just the subject
line says to God I'm waiting for a test
they can do that that would be a neat
trick notes all right nice um okay so
okay so that's the big advice I've built
a nice tablet version and if we get it
to crash on air while we're just tapping
through it that suggests that you
probably want to do a little bit more
testing it's a really kind of a really
important part of your app development
is to really give it a workout and one
of the one of the key tips I have for
testing so there's a bunch of stuff you
can read about using unit tests and test
frameworks and getting different devices
to test it and all those sorts of things
one thing which a lot of people tend to
forget is actually just getting people
to use your apps and you might think
well then uh how many people would you
really qualified to test it the best
people to test your apps are the people
who phones your concert
we fixing who are always messing
something are putting their phone in
Swahili and not being sure how to change
it back to english or whatever their
native language is they're the ones you
want testing your app because they will
find all the edge cases all the race
conditions all the simple things that
can happen so yeah definitely test it as
thoroughly and as robustly as you can
you can't probably run a better site by
sharing your attend your test app apk
with a small subset of people I would go
a step further I would say to put it on
their devices specifically because
anyone who's able to install an apk by
themselves it's too advanced fee alright
so yes put it on their phone sneakily
and say oh look there's a new app on
your phone you should try it okay
perfect so we've got a little bit more
time right I think we're about 2/3 of
the way through it's already all right
let's have a look at one of our other
favorite categories so this is battery
disk so I suspect this is a widget as
well
excellent ok so what they've done really
well here is if I click it if I just
open it
they have animation can you show us
again no no animation oh that was the
the ad came in animated but so this is
primarily is with go back go back
alright sorry sorry let's try it again
battery disk yeah holds out well pick
well picked totally missed that
eagle-eyes on Fred um so what they've
done like a attention to detail which is
nice and also so this is primarily a
widget but if you open the app it
provides useful information here so you
can see all of the stuff right here the
only thing that they maybe do wrong here
is that doesn't actually say that it's a
widget you got it's implied here
temperature on big widget and text
inside widget but you probably want to
mention just you know a line of text
which says you know don't forget to
install the widget or actually back to
your point earlier you know for users
for regular you know consumer users that
may not be familiar with widgets they
may not know what these two instructions
mean precisely I mean if this if the app
as it is is exactly what they want then
you're in good shape
but it doesn't hurt to tell people that
some of the other functionality exists
so this is all nice we got battery disk
in status bar
it shows it's showing both Celsius and
Fahrenheit for the temperature it is
thirty-six and ninety six point eight
Wow
it's warm inside of the battery um I'm
not sure what this does so if I hit star
it takes me to to the app in great oh
it's for writing a listening back okay
okay well that's that's not an obnoxious
way of giving way to ask you know it's a
good practice to ask people hey give me
a feedback but the icon lets include a
nice that into it
yeah maybe you could have the Google
Play icon I'm not I'm not quite sure
what the right solution is there but you
know on the one hand I guess it's fine
because it's an explicit user action you
don't know what to expect so I guess
that's fine and then you've got the
about okay that's that's fine and the
the eye icon there indicates the that
the about stuff so that's fine you've
got a menu button of shame so you've got
a menu button doesn't do anything so for
so all you need to do is set your target
SDK to 14 and that will disappear just
one line change okay that's that's
perfect so let's let's move on so this
is an existing battery widget as week
exactly so you can see that last weeks
if you watched last week's beautiful
battery widget you remove the big one
that's right so we can't really tell
exactly right so you can see it's still
beautiful widget and their color has
changed due to the decreased battery
life let's go to widget here and go to
what was the name of this one battery
disk battery disk that's good further
back all right every disk okay all right
perfect so let's go with the drop the
big one on the screen first
okay here's bigger that is big nice I'm
gonna drop the small one on there as
well so we can compare okay nice nice
either of them resize no no okay
that's actually that's actually quite
nice actually I like this circular look
rather than sort of mock real life
things so that actually works for me I
think it's just it's just that Tron
style yeah
yeah so one thing you could do and maybe
I mean they're a bunch of themes which I
think you're just going to change the
color but one thing you could consider
is to sort of follow the footpaths of a
lot of other with battery widgets and
change the color of the sort of the
circles dynamically as the as the
battery decreases yeah and one of the
things so I'm not sure I'm gonna I'm
going to go go on a limb and assume that
these are PNG files with set colors
which is generally a pretty good
approach but if you have static images
which have gradients and those sorts of
things you can draw them dynamically
which will let you which will let you be
able to choose whatever colors you want
and have you know a vast range of
gradients and colors normally that's not
a great idea because it's expensive to
have to keep redrawing if you've got
something like a compass where you're
moving things around gets expensive this
is constant right so you can even draw
it once save it as a well recorded as a
bitmap and then keep keep using it with
different colors it also helps decrease
the size of your application exactly and
then you can have a thousand different
themes and it doesn't increase the size
of your app at all because it's just
different color values that you're
inserting into the code at runtime so
that's to consider and you can do the
same thing using gradient drawables as
well as an option that's presuming
you're not already doing that otherwise
yeah I think it looks pretty good I
don't know that I would put the
temperature as a first-class citizen but
I guess that's one of the options in the
in the settings isn't it yes so I can
choose not to show the temperature not
sure the text inside I can see if there
were jets refresh themselves looks at in
Fahrenheit and okay now this is an
interesting no no that's fine okay all
right so I've taken all the text out
which is nice so now you will get the
drawn it so it's a proper tronic look
absolutely so we've also added it to the
status bar so it's up here that's nice
so they've you've actually done a fully
custom notification there so there must
be a bitmap that they're creating
dynamically so you clearly you know how
to do dynamic bitmap generation so maybe
you already wants to be heard of me in
which case I apologize our nice work if
not you already know how to do it so can
consider taking that to the next level
for the widgets themselves actually
quite like that I think yeah that looks
that looks tidy I think you may want to
have a little bit more padding it feels
like it's going right up against the
edges which through a circle makes it
look a little bit cramped so maybe just
make it a little bit smaller but um I
like it like this what do you think as
far as as far as your battery widgets go
how does this rank
I like the big one I like I like the big
one the Tron one yeah can I put it
Center
oh oh it changes color look at that
that's nice I can't put it setter
that's nice I just actually changed I
thought it was related to me picking it
up and there you go so they are one step
ahead of me they are changing the colors
dynamically nice all of the feedback
they're implementing it in real time and
the way that they are on the fly yeah
and push it to my device I don't know
how you did that but well done ah um
okay so again seeing is who you seem to
know what you're doing when it comes to
dynamic generation of stuff what I would
suggest again here is maybe make this
resizable because it's kind of an
awesome look I might want to make that
my entire screen make one of the screens
that so having a resizable widget would
kind of be nice yeah I bet I Louis yeah
it's pretty good it's pretty good nicely
done
the Battle of the battery widgets
continues okay so we've got five minutes
I think before we need to stop we've got
three more apps so buzz through these
pretty quickly the the lightning round
as the the games folks like to call it
okay English training choose an activity
to practice so I have to speak pretty
good English because I lived in England
Fred Pia has lived in America for like
your whole life no no no a big portion
of the portion of it but it's still
America so you can speak decent American
but I don't know about your English what
would you like to practice a field gap
film I can't so look five questions Time
Attack hell yes
all right she has been murdering her
husband
right take a word Fred oh she's being
charged over come on man when Bob back
tonight she'll cook the dinner excellent
so there aren't too many people here
this is actually a question of answer
game Oh timed despite of last question
his office is on the second rule well it
could by I'm willing to go with either
floor or level right so easy boom
school four out of five yeah I'll help
him to it I'm holding the team up so I
wasn't bad
and actually the look and feel was
immediately obvious even though we were
being time pressure situation it was
remediate Lee obviously right what you
needed to do a hangman game do they do
have a hangman game that's nice Wow okay
let's go with II do you love our vials
ah jeez ah ends are always good whoa you
think Fred right I tried anything I like
it
G no oh it's looking bad Peas Wow you
know I don't think I know I do not know
well that's good let's go back to
reviewing the ABS yeah let's not focus
on our inability to play hangman let's
say let's continue with yeah so okay so
what I like about this is it's designed
for someone who is learning to speak
English which means you want to have
minimal language and lots of pictures so
one of the things which I would point
out here is that it's not immediately
obvious what all of these things mean so
gap-fill as soon as you go into it you
understand it but it's not hugely
meaningful and you've used it a
contraction here or an abbreviation I
should say your reg verbs which I'm
going to go ahead and assume is
irregular verbs but using an
abbreviation for people who aren't
necessarily great English language
speakers could be a problem
it definitely makes sense to spell out
the word
yeah exactly exactly and uses simple
words as you can to try and help people
out if we have oh it's developed by two
students from engineering school nice
perfect so and you've used the action
bar here the about dialogue is correct
there's no menu button of shame and
again it's it's simple there's nothing
else you can do here but click through
these and find out how to how to speak
English better so I'm going to assume
that that just means reset all
statistics yes please
otherwise yeah I mean it's basically
it's straightforward it's big it's
visually based I think you're definitely
on the right track you know primarily
because I wanted to nice I'm gonna have
to go ahead and assume that it is Ian
whoa
I really hope that's the camera not my
eyes otherwise I need to go to an
optometrist
how many questions let's go with five
let's make it not the Time Attack and
hit start
yeah um push and speak so translate
that's half a word that's half a word I
don't understand hmm
serving brings up yes to serve Oh
so mean oh so now this I guess is
translate the word in for Friday see no
wasn't obvious to me that I needed to
know how to speak French before watching
this in English well yes but I didn't
realize I was gonna be tested on it
uh-huh okay so okay so it's going to ask
us a French word translate it and push
and speak it in English I suppose so
let's try this the commodities manatees
yeah I didn't get that inexactitude mmm
you got a guess no yeah and you want to
take a guess
well I'll just follow Ratos and
exactitude
no matches found let me try it for you
inexactitude it's basically you know I
will see now that's that's the same and
inexactitude is inaccurate all right
let's stop this humiliation and to her
and return from that so so one thing
which I would say actually two things I
would say the first is that clearly this
seems like it's targeted at French
speakers looking to learn English so
that should probably made more clear
particularly once you go into the
vocabulary section because otherwise
that's not gonna be helpful for non
French speakers probably want the French
version of this first which is maybe the
first the the for beginners you learn
French and then you move on to English
the thing that may be backwards um I
want to check with the icon design I was
going to point out the icon slag it says
English training but that's an American
boy so you know as an Australian who
lived in England I object unless you
just rename it to American training
leave that one so yeah it's interesting
so I would I don't know maybe more
people associate English with with
American than anything else but that I
found that a little bit jarring it's a
pretty minor comment I don't know what
the irregular verbs are even though
we're out of time you do realize yeah
exactly I said have known it's like a
French app which is using American
instead of English that's how strong
this goes like the the French
unwillingness right even associate
English with England that's a big call
okay
we're out of time so so I think I'm
gonna hold off these next two apps I'm
going to look at them next week's time
absolutely we got Sian accent easy voice
recorder both of which seem pretty
interesting so we'll check them out next
week in the meantime we're gonna sign
off and in and Damned in an incredibly
weird hat can we hope we can only hope
so stay tuned and you'll find out if Dan
is wearing a ridiculous hat or not and
Ian will be here as well just being
ridiculous in general somebody get yeah
yeah
all right well wait for him to get here
within in the meantime we'll be here
again next week I think yes no yet right
yeah we'll be here next game in two
weeks right I oh I hope if I see hope
it's more than two weeks I really do um
so yeah so continue to put your apps in
the moderator queue we'll check out
another bunch next week and stick around
for the game's review and yeah we'll see
you next week see you guys